ich bin hier gerade im innotruck hier
könnt ihr euch Zukunftstechnologien
anschauen die hoffentlich bald unser
Leben verändern werden unter anderem
auch diese Solarfolie hier die sehr dünn
ist und flexibel ist ich habe mich so
ein bisschen gefragt was ist denn mit
herkömmlichen Photovoltaik Modulen
falsch genau das habe ich hier ein
Wissenschaftler gefragt nämlich dr Peter
Stoffels erstmal ist ein herkömmlichen
Photovoltaik-Modulen nichts verkehrt das
ist eine dezentrale Technologie die an
ganz vielen Flächen angebracht werden
kann aber es gibt eben auch sehr viele
Flächen an dem man es nicht anbringen
kann aufgrund des Gewichtes aufgrund der
Form teilweise auch und da wäre eine
flexiblere Lösung tatsächlich schöner
das ganze kommt ein bisschen daher
zustande dass in solchen Solarmodulen ja
Silicium als Hauptbestandteil drin ist
und das hat eben ein gewisses Gewicht es
gibt Bewegungen dass man eben
Solarfolien herstellt die ihr dann immer
noch Silizium basiert sind die sind
schon ein wenig flexibler aber noch
nicht so wie man sich das gerne wünschen
würde und da bietet eben die organische
Photovoltaik tatsächlich eine
Möglichkeit auch Folien herzustellen die
all diese Syrien erfüllen der Hersteller
dieser organischen Solarfolie heißt
heliatec die haben auch dieses Exponat
hier zur Verfügung gestellt und wie so
eine Folie hergestellt wird genau das
schauen wir uns jetzt an
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich bei heliatek in Dresden wo
diese Solarfolien hier hergestellt
werden und ich spreche jetzt gleich hier
mit dem Geschäftsführer Guido fantat-
die ganze Welt braucht immer mehr Strom
wir haben eigentlich nicht genug
Rohmaterial in das alles zu generieren
deswegen haben wir diese ganze Krise in
Energie und so weiter und es wäre so
schön wenn man Strom generieren kann
ohne sich zu bemühen über romaterial die
große Vision von Guido und seiner Firma
ist es dass irgendwann in der Zukunft
quasi jede Oberfläche sei es von einem
Gebäude einem Auto oder einem Schiff
genutzt werden kann um Energie zu
erzeugen das Problem ist mit
herkömmlichen Photovoltaikanlagen ist
das nicht immer möglich sie sind schwer
müssen fest verschraubt werden und sind
zum Beispiel für runde Flächen nur
schlecht verwendbar für Glasflächen
schon gar nicht
die Lösung wie wäre es wenn wir
Solarzellen nicht in dicke Module packen
sondern sie stattdessen auf hauchdünne
flexible Folien aufbringen und das macht
er jetzt wirklich versuchen von
organische Materialien
vollständige Solarpaneele zu machen hört
sich super ab ist aber sehr schwer es
wirklich Wissenschaft von der Ground ab
also von Materialien ist Prozessen und
Maschinen genau denn dafür braucht es
ein komplett neues chemisches Verfahren
das ist so ein bisschen wie wenn man
versucht einen Röhrenfernseher immer
flacher zu bekommen irgendwann gibt es
einfach eine physische Grenze ab der man
die Dinger aufgrund ihrer Bauweise
einfach nicht mehr flacher bekommt da
muss dann eine komplett neue Technologie
her OLED zum Beispiel und das ist auch
ein sehr treffender Vergleich denn die
Technologie für die organischen
Solarfolien ist tatsächlich sehr gut
vergleichbar mit der organischen
Funktionsweise von OLED Bildschirmen die
einen wandeln Strom zu Licht die anderen
wandeln Licht zu Strom
gestartet wird mit einer riesigen Rolle
von 1,30 m Breite und einer Länge von
unglaublichen 2,6 km diese Rolle wird
für die einzelnen Panels meist gedrittet
aber auch Module mit der halben oder
sogar der ganzen Breite sind möglich auf
diese Trägerfolie werden mehrere sehr
dünne Schichten der organischen
Materialien aufgedampft diese nach
diesem Arbeitsschritt aber extrem
empfindlich deswegen ist es äußerst
wichtig dass die Luft in dieser Anlage
möglichst trocken ist im nächsten
Schritt werden dann die elektronischen
Leiterbahnen angebracht und das ganze
abschließend mit einer Schutzschicht
gegen Wasser und andere Einflüsse
versiegelt heraus kommen Module mit
einer Dicke von wenigen Millimetern und
genügend Flexibilität um sie auf allen
erdenklichen Oberflächen anzubringen
dafür kommen sie auf der Rückseite
praktischerweise direkt mit einer
Klebeschicht die auf Beton Metall Holz
oder Glas problemlos haftet und dabei
auch Wind und Wetter trotzt und nicht
nur das die Technologie ist dabei auch
nach richtig wie Guido behauptet wieso
ist das Grün es ist organisch es ist
auch nachhaltig weil die Rohmaterialien
sind in überflüssig anwesend überall
Kohlenstoff Wasserstoff Stickstoff alles
was eigentlich wo gut ich den Pflanzen
und ihren Fondant sind das was wir
benutzen sind eilig die Natur natürliche
Elemente von Mutter Erde reinbleihen
kann glaub mir hier kein Seltene Erden
und das ist mindestens genauso wichtig
wie die gewonnene Flexibilität im
Gegensatz zu herkömmlichen Solarpanels
sind die Folien komplett unabhängig von
Ressourcen die ansonsten vor allem aus
China kommen mit der Ausnahme von
einigen elektronischen Komponenten aus
Japan wurden alle Materialien aus der EU
stammen das sorgt auch für einen
vergleichsweise kleinen co2-rucksack
lediglich 8 Gramm CO2-Äquivalent pro
Kilowattstunde Strom sollen die Module
in Dresden verursachen was weniger wäre
als herkömmliche Solarkraft und sogar
Windkraft die energierücklaufzeit
also die Zeit bis das CO2 der gesamten
Lebensphase der Folie durch die
gewonnene Energie vom Modul selbst
ausgeglichen wird soll damit bei nur
wenigen Monaten liegen im Vergleich zu
ein bis zwei Jahren die es bei einer
herkömmlichen PV-Anlage dauern kann
darüber und so ziemlich über alles
andere zum Thema erneuerbare Energien
haben wir übrigens in unserer bisher
längsten Doku hier gesprochen
gut wenig CO2 ist schon mal toll aber
wie sieht es denn mit der
recycel-barkeit aus heutzutage sieht ein
paar Sachen die man einfach rausnehmen
kann und wieder benutzen kann der Rest
verbrennen wir und hat keine Schaden für
die Umgebung an und die Wärme die
benutzt um wieder Strom zu generieren
aber was wir gerne mögen ist das
wirklich auseinanderzunehmen wenn sie
Materialien zu benutzen und damit
arbeiten wir zusammen mit ein paar
Universitäten und dieser
Recyclingprozess wirklich aufzusetzen
wir haben ganz 20 Jahren Zeit weiß ich
aber wir haben ein paar Jahreszeiten was
zu bauen das ist ganz wichtig für uns
waren weil es ist nicht nur um grün zum
Anfang es ist schön von Anfang im
Fertigung im Benutzung es sollte auch
total drin sein am Ende die Frage zum
Recycling kam übrigens von euch auf
Instagram wo ich euch schon vor dem
Interview gefragt habe was euch alles an
den Solarfolien interessieren würde wenn
ihr bei zukünftigen Interviews auch
gerne Fragen beisteuern wollt dann fol
gerne auf Instagram at dr Watson da
rufen wir zu sowas immer mal wieder auf
und was euch anscheinend damit Abstand
am meisten interessiert hat sind die
hard facts zur Leistung klar so eine
Technologie bringt natürlich nichts wenn
sie nicht auch in absehbarer Zeit
dieselbe Leistung erbringt wie
herkömmliche photovoltaik-technologien
also Butter bei die Fische hier kommen
die hard facts aktuell haben die Folien
noch einen Wirkungsgrad von nur etwa 8%.
das ist deutlich schlechter als das was
moderne marktübliche Panels leisten die
liegen meistens so zwischen 15 und 22
Prozent heliatec forscht aber intensiv
daran den Wirkungsgrad in den nächsten
Jahren deutlich zu steigern 8%
Wirkungsgrad das bedeutet eine Leistung
von etwa 65 bis 70 Watt Peak pro
Quadratmeter und ihr habt auch nach der
Kilowattstunde pro Kilowatt Peak gefragt
laut Guido liegt dieser Wert in Dresden
mal ungefähr 1000
aber in Bezug auf den Standort gibt es
auch gute Nachrichten Tests haben
ergeben dass der Wirkungsgrad der Folien
fast
temperaturunabhängig ist im Gegensatz zu
normalen Solarpanels die schwächer
werden sobald die Außentemperatur vom
Optimalbereich abweicht und die 8%
sollen auch über längere Zeit gehalten
werden können über eine
durchschnittliche Lebensdauer von 20
Jahren hält die Folie angeblich 80%
ihrer Leistung das ist zwar etwas
weniger als man es von den meisten
herkömmlichen Modulen erwarten würde
aber auch dieser Wert wird sich
hoffentlich noch verbessern dafür muss
man sich keine Gedanken über brühende
Hitze Hagel oder Sturmböen machen weil
die Folie nicht brechen kann wie das
Glas oder die Zellen von normalen
Solarmodulen tun und genau diese
Eigenschaften will heliatec auch
beibehalten wären sie ihr Ziel von 25%
Wirkungsgrad anstreben das ist laut
Guidos eigene Aussage noch 7 bis 8 Jahre
entfernt wobei er als CEO da vermutlich
noch eher optimistisch unterwegs ist
letztendlich ist dieser Vergleich aber
auch gar nicht so wichtig denn Fakt ist
die Solarfolie erlaubt uns Flächen in
Strom zu verwandeln die vorher überhaupt
nicht nutzbar gewesen wären so gesehen
muss man die 8% eigentlich mit 0%
Wirkungsgrad vergleichen wir sehen noch
nicht so gut wie normaler Solarpanel
langfristig denken wir dass das wirklich
ein ein Ersatz ist für normaler
solopaneele aber das schöne für uns ist
jetzt dass es gibt einen Markt von
Gebäudeoberfläche wo es schwierig
treuer aus verboten ist um normaler
schwerer Solarpaneele zu installieren
und das ist unser unser erstes Mal ich
sage über die Zukunft wenn sie normaler
Solarpanel benutzen kann bitte machen es
aber wenn es schwierig ist ruf mich an
ob das auch für E-Autos funktioniert
klar theoretisch schon nur ist der
Reichweiten Gewinn hier wirklich
marginal maximal ein Prozent Akku am Tag
wenn es gut geht und die Sonne wirklich
viel scheint Autos die nur durch
Solarzellen auf dem Dach geladen und
gefahren werden können sind leider noch
Science Fiction dafür ist die Fläche
eines Autos einfach zu klein gleiches
gilt für Smartphones es würde
theoretisch gehen ja aber es bringt
einfach zu wenig als dass man es im
Alltag wirklich merken würde und als das
ist die Mehrkosten rechtfertigt was uns
zum vielleicht spannendsten Punkt bringt
was kosten diese Solarfolien eigentlich
man muss rechnen ungefähr 200 Euro pro
Quadratmeter und das ist das weiß ich
was ist sehr viel ich sage immer es geht
um Strom und CO2 also ich habe den
niedrigste co2-fit wird und ein sehr
ordentliches Angebot für den Sport und
wenn mein wirkungsrad höher wird hat man
mehr Strom die Leute sagen immer wie
viel Euro pro was und das wird noch und
das geht schneller runter das komplette
Interview mit Guido geht übrigens über
45 Minuten und ist super interessant er
spricht darüber noch sehr viele
spannende Sachen die wir hier in diesem
Video leider gar nicht unterbringen
konnten aber wenn ihr das komplette
ungeschnittene Interview sehen wollt
dann könnt ihr uns auf patreon
unterstützen über patreon bekommt ihr
zum Beispiel Videos von uns vor allen
anderen zu sehen es gibt exklusive
Livestreams oder eben Interviews in
voller Länge und das wichtigste die
unterstützt damit auch noch uns und
unsere Arbeit spannende Wissenschaft zu
verbreiten ich habe euch mal einen Link
unten in die Videobeschreibung gepackt
ein weiterer wichtiger Faktor ist die
Massenproduktion das bringt uns ja
nichts eine coole Solarfolie zu haben
wir brauchen ganz ganz viele davon die
in Dresden ist theoretisch in der Lage
zwei Millionen Quadratmeter Solarfolie
pro Jahr zu produzieren in der Praxis
erreicht heliatec diesen Output aber
noch lange nicht weil sie gerade noch
dabei sind die Produktion richtig
hochzufahren und selbst wenn zwei
Millionen Quadratmeter sind ein
Bruchteil der Fläche die aktuell mit
Solarpanels bedeckt wird alleine
Deutschland waren das 2019 mehr als 300
Millionen Quadratmeter das
Umweltbundesamt schätzt außerdem dass
bis 2030 weitere 75.000 bis 80.000
Hektar nötig sein werden um die
aktuellen Klimaziele Deutschlands
erreichen zu können und diese Zahlen
beziehen sich nur auf Solar Freiflächen
also keine Dächer oder Offshore-Anlagen
deswegen auch an euch der Hinweis wenn
ihr bis jetzt vorhat direkt zum Hörer zu
greifen und durch eure eigene Solarfolie
zu bestellen spart euch die Energie es
wird leider leider noch einige Jahre
dauern bis diese Technologie so
wirtschaftlich ist dass Sie bei uns
Privatkunden landet vorher liefert
heliatec erstmal an Großkunden die
riesige Mengen auf einmal abnehmen wenn
es dann aber soweit ist dann könnt ihr
hier auf dem Kanal definitiv ein Update
Video dazu erwarten also abonniert gerne
jetzt schon mal den Kanal und das nicht
zu verpassen und in dem Video in ein
paar Jahren können wir dann auch
hoffentlich neues zu einer wie ich finde
besonders spannenden Weiterentwicklung
in diesem Bereich berichten nämlich
transparente Solarfolien unser Traum ist
das jedes oberflach stromgeneriert auch
Glas auch Fenster und wenn man unser
Film ohne diese Klebstoff und ohne diese
Schutzfolie einfach in das Glas
integrieren kann aber ein fast völlig
transparentes Fenster was Strom
generiert haben wir auch schon
untersucht wie nicht transparent muss
das sein die transparent darf das sein
was ist der Effekt auf der Wirklichkeit
und das funktioniert
das ist eigentlich der der nächste
Schritt ein Schritt mit mega viel
Potenzial stellt euch das mal vor
komplett verglast die Bürogebäude dafür
gibt es so viele die könnten alle so
quasi zu einem riesigen Solarpanel
verwandelt werden ohne dass man etwas
davon sieht dafür wird die transparente
Solarfolie in den Zwischenraum einer
Doppelverglasung eingelassen was da noch
automatisch für den nötigen Schutz sorgt
zwar werden die Fenster so auch ein
klein wenig dunkler aber wohl nur um ca
5%, was tatsächlich kaum auffällt und
weil die Solarzellen auch Wellenlängen
außerhalb des sichtbaren Spektrums
verarbeiten können bleibe der
Wirkungsgrad dabei quasi gleich erste
Hersteller arbeiten hier mit heliatech
schon zusammen wobei es auch hier noch
ein paar Hürden gibt die überwunden
werden müssen bevor das ganze in Serie
gehen kann
für uns ist es auch eine fast eine Ehre
und zu arbeiten an einem so wichtige
Technologie wie wirklich ein ein sehr
großes Problem von uns allen versucht zu
lösen das ist Strom ohne ohne Ende und
mit der niedrigsten CO2 Fußabdruck die
man finden kann und dass das zweite wird
immer wichtig wenn ihr jetzt noch Fragen
habt dann schreibt uns gerne unten in
die youtube-kommentare und diskutiert
mit uns denn das Team von heliatec hat
uns zugesichert sie wollen uns auf jeden
Fall beim Beantworten der Fragen helfen
hoffentlich bleibt keine Frage
unbeantwortet vielen vielen Dank an das
Team vom innottruck und das
Bundesministerium für Bildung und
Forschung für die Unterstützung bei
diesem Video vielen Dank an heliatec
dass wir hier drehen durften und jetzt
alles gezeigt habt und an euch vielen
Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt immer
neugierig euer Cedric